l'année qui se termine aura été celle du
climat qui s'emballe et des éléments qui
se déchaînent comme jamais à la grandeur
du canada en tête de la liste
d'environnement canada le dôme de
chaleur qui a étouffé l'ouest canadien
la fin du mois de juin et provoqué le
décès prématuré de plus de 600 personnes
à vancouver
le 29 juin à layton en colombie
britannique
il a fait presque 50 degrés un record
national absolue ici en train de manger
de la glace moitié gelé nos jours dans
l'ouest mais en novembre des trombes
d'eau se déversent sur la région de
vancouver jusqu'à 300 mm en l'espace de
deux jours dans certains secteurs des
milliers de familles délogées les fermes
qui disparaissent le bétail qu'on
récupère en motomarine la désolation
le pays entier est également frappée par
une longue et pénible période de
sécheresse causant le des plus faibles
rendements agricoles annuelle jamais
enregistrée
on observe aussi des sommets inégalés en
termes de feux de forêt au total plus de
15 ans incendies dévastateurs qui ont
détruit l'équivalent d'une fois et demie
le territoire de l'île du prince édouard
en surface de forêt sinon doigts croisés
face à ce cas de la pluie assez près
pour que tout redevienne à
noter également des tornades plus
fréquents qui frères en syrie dont
quatre qui s'abattent sur le sud du
québec le 21 juin dernier
de plus trouble 1 pensent les
spécialistes c'est qu'en raison des
changements climatiques ce qui semble
être l'exception pourrait devenir la
règle sur les tasses à long terme oui il
faut se préparer à vie ces éléments là
il faut s'adapter il faut aussi faire
des choix qu'entend les changements
climatiques personne ne les combattez
choix qui doivent plutôt serait vraiment
nu environnement canada estime que
l'année climatique 2021 est probablement
la plus coûteuse de notre histoire sur
les plans économiques humains et
environnementaux
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal